we already know the doj is targeting
conservatives look at what they've done
to president Trump to the people caught
up in the January 6 drag net but now
they're new concerns that the IRS is
doing the same back to its old tricks a
decade after that Infamous IRS Chief
Lois learner remember when she was
accused of carrying out vendettas
against conservative groups the agency
is reportedly targeting conservative
groups yet again the American
accountability Foundation which has
published multiple exposes on Biden
nominees that led to some actually
getting pulled is now being audited and
at risk of losing its 501c3 tax exempt
status what is going on here joining me
now is Ohio Senator JD Vance Senator um
I I have to remind everybody that the
Biden Administration wants to increase
the IRS headcount by nearly
90,000 employees at a time when we
should be cutting government spending
but uh is this all just a coincidence
about this group getting targeted
getting audited I should
say I don't think it's a coincidence at
all Laura we have to remember of course
that the IRS 10 years ago admitted that
they were targeting conservatives they
said they would never happen again and
yet we have evidence that it's happening
at this very moment uh the thing I'd say
about the aaf the American
accountability Foundation Laura is that
they're extremely effective there have
been multiple Biden Administration
nominations that I think that we've been
able to defeat because they have
revealed incredibly gross things about
about their past statements about their
past views so these guys are doing
incredibly good work and here's really
the goal of this Laura what the IRS is
trying to do is is basically send a
signal that if you are doing effective
work on behalf of the conservative
movement you got to you got to have your
head on a swivel you got to be looking
around your shoulder to make sure that
the IRS isn't going to come after you
it's fundamentally an assault on
people's First Amendment rights and it's
using the government it's another
example of using the government to
Target political opponents as opposed to
effectively administer the laws of the
country this is a very new thing we're
seeing in American government it's very
dangerous and we have to call it out and
we have to fight against
it now the 90,000 agents that we keep
hearing about there were a number of
efforts to try to pull back the funding
on on the IRS whatever happened with
that I keep having people come up to me
asking me what's going on with that and
I never know have an really good
answer
well one update Laura is actually uh
myself and a colleague Roger Marshall
one of a great Senators um one of my
best friends in the Senate actually uh
he and I went to the senate floor just a
couple of days ago and tried to cut $14
billion out of that additional IRS
funding Mike Johnson the speaker of the
house has been doing and pushing similar
legislation on the house side of course
every single Democrat voted to stop in
the United States Senate even the
so-called moderates what we're seeing
here with the weaponization of the IRS
is that no Democrat is willing to stand
up and say enough is enough so long as
you with the one hand give these guys
tons of money and with the other hand
Empower them to Target their political
opponents you're going to have a
fundamentally distorted political system
a lack of Justice in this country that
is unfortunately what we're H what we
have we're trying to push back against
it Laura but unfortunately with with
Chuck Schumer and Democrats in the
majority there's only so much that we
can do it's yet another reason why we've
got to push back against the Democratic
majorities in 24 yeah Laura and if I can
make just one final Point look I
understand everybody sort of looks at
this I'm a conservative they say a
conservative is complaining about what
the IRS is doing to conservatives this
is really not about left versus right
this is about whether we have functional
constitutional government in this
country if the IRS can go after you
because of what you think or what you
believe or what you do we no longer live
in a free country that's what this is
all about and if you think they're not
going to eventually use it against your
politics whatever they might be it's
ridiculous they certainly
will well Senator uh this has to be
stopped got to win the Senate back next
year that means strong conservatives
running Senator thank you hey Sean
Hannity here hey click here to subscribe
to Fox News YouTube page and catch our
hottest interviews and most compelling
analysis you will not get it anywhere
else